Tom Izzo head coach of Michigan State
the Spartans ghosts party and Tom joins
us now how's the voice coach great Dan
how's yours it mines great minds never
felt better sounded better it's velvety
what did you do you get a lot of sleep
yeah that's the only reason my mind goes
out you know I I got a job that I don't
get as much sleep so that's that's not a
reason mine goes what keeps you up at
night
Texas Tech media those three you know
three keep me up but now you know I mean
I I swear to god this has been a year
where not a lot of those things keep me
up I just I just have a lot on my mind
because you don't get these
opportunities that often you know I mean
we've got a good team it's not the most
talented team it you've seen us have and
but we got a heck of a quarterback and
we got some guys that that have bought
in and and we're very connected team
were pretty good in all areas offense
defense rebounding which is the problem
is we're going to play a team that's
elite in one area that's their defensive
area and improving much on the offensive
side if somebody hadn't seen Cash's
Winston play how would you describe him
I was going to church and lining a bunch
of people up and saying oh that guy's in
the choir really you know yeah he's you
know he's six forties I don't know what
he weighs but he's not an imposing
looking guy doesn't have incredible
speed he's just he has a very high
basketball IQ he is the herky-jerky kind
of is good with his left hand is what
his right hand which makes him a little
quicker than he actually is because he
can go either way you can you can't
force him one way or the other he likes
to go both ways and you know he's just a
guy that really sees the court and can
score the ball there's not many people
that I've had here Scott Skiles was one
as an assistant here
could score it and pass it together some
point guards are scoring point guard
some are just passing point guards there
very few that can do both once the last
time you prepared for a player that had
anywhere near the talent his eye on
Williamson I know what he really did
impress me I think one thing that
happened in that game was really
impressive
Kenney going took a shot the top of the
key kind of late in the game that Zion
blocked the problem is ion was under the
basket when he laughed and and I told
Kenny in that I said why don't you pump
fake I'm gonna fall on to me he looks at
mrs. coach he was 15 feet away and I
couldn't even argue with him I said good
point so the next time the reason we got
in the shot is we screens ion because if
he's a guy Dan that I think was great
for college basketball because if you
when you got there with them not only
did he play with so much energy passion
but he had you know he had some fight no
man he was good defensively good
offensive ly he was a star maybe the
star of all stars and all he's got to
work on some things to get better for
the next level but I tell you what his
motor is great and his he seemed to be
an incredible teammate not selfish I
enjoyed playing against him I I didn't
enjoy preparing for him but when he got
on the floor I just can't appreciate it
all he brings to the game tougher to
prepare for a great defensive team or
great offensive team because because I
said this to my players for a hundred
years you know every year I get together
and I find out who won the
you know the national championship in
football and who won in the World
Championship in football and who won it
basketball come on in hockey and who won
in baseball and if that was the same you
know the best defensive teams even the
Warriors every times what they're on
there they were the best defensive teams
if you look at football every year you
know the teams that have the best
defense wins if you look at Alabama and
Clemson you know the teams with the best
defense wins and and even in Hawk in
baseball you know it's the picture it's
the goalie and so I guess I'd say that
it's worse to prepare for a great
defensive teams and offensive teams but
also trying to recruit defense how hard
is it possible yeah it's impossible you
know I ivory cleared about three players
here that I recruited stripped a kid
named Travis Walt and I said you know we
need a tough lockdown guy and but you
don't normally do that those aren't the
McDonald's all-americans hell those guys
aren't even the Burger King
all-americans they're just got it down
the list you know and and and yet in
saying all that I had a kid Gary Harris
a couple years ago that was a great
two-way player he was a score that could
guard that's almost illegal in our
country you know to be able to do both
unfortunately for me cover is six six
and he's a scorer that can guard and
that's why he is a you know a top notch
maybe draft pick so when he can do both
that's really special
well great run I got you winning at all
so don't screw up my bracket okay
oh that's bunches I did one bracket and
I and I picked you guys to win for that
and then fun being on the show all these
years and hopefully if we do we can be
on the show and have a relaxing fun
moment I was actually I wrote Michigan
but my intern Mario he put down Michigan
State and so I
yeah cuz I no no no I did not have
Dayton Flyers in there all right Thank
You coach that's Tom Izzo for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]